Let's go next to Scipio from California,
Scipio from California. You're on the air.
Scipio, California, you're on the air.
Hey, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Hey, this is so cool. I'm a long time
listener, but first time caller. Thank you.
I wanted to ask we're like a year
into covid-19 impacting the US,
and there's still people that just won't
take the guidelines seriously at all. Like
just this week, I had to go inside an office
and I didn't see one person wearing a mask.
And I don't know at this point, like,
what can you do to try and convince
those people it's as serious as it is?
Because I try to share information
and citations with friends and family and on
my social media, but it just seems like I'm
screaming into the void. So I just
wanted to get your thoughts online.
Sadly, at this point, at this point, I don't
know that there is much to do. And, you know,
unfortunately, let me let me back up. Fortunately,
cases are going down, vaccination is increasing,
and hopefully over the next four to six months,
we are going to see a dramatic change to the
circumstances. Coronavirus may become seasonal,
sort of like the flu, whatever things are going to
improve. Most of those people who have not been
paying attention to the guidelines all along,
they may be responsible for the deaths of
others. Most of them, of course, will survive
and they will be re they will see their actions
reinforced because they'll say, look, we got
through it. I never wore a mask. I did whatever
the hell I wanted. If I got it, it wasn't that bad
for me. And unfortunately, we're sort of at the
point where I think they're beyond reach and they
will benefit from vaccination just as much as
everybody who's been well-behaved will benefit.
It will reinforce their belief that
it wasn't that bad ever. And I don't
know that there's much that we can do about it.
Yeah, that's unfortunately the conclusion
I've sort of arrived at as well, but
yeah, I'm glad it's we're at least
seeing light at the end of the tunnel.
Now, are the bosses not enforcing
is there not a mask policy or is
there one? But it's not enforced.
At the places that I've been to, like the
person who's sort of running the office,
like they've been there and they've
also been without a massage and like.
Yeah, I've seen it where the people who would
be in charge of whatever that context is like,
they're also not right. So it
is like a work culture thing.
Got it. Got it. Got it. Yeah. I mean, it's
it's happening in many parts of the country,
more in some than others. And eventually they're
all going to get bailed. The ones that survive,
which of course, statistically will be most of
them will sort of be bailed out by vaccines.
Yeah, yeah, I didn't know if you I know a lot of
people have been talking about the snowstorm, but
I don't know if you saw that Bloomberg interview.
Dan Woodsmen, he's a senior director for Electric
Reliability Council of Texas. And he even came out
and said this nonsense about wind turbines is just
that is nonsense. And he sort of breaks down like
how much energy it makes up and how it doesn't
make sense that people are blaming, like wind
turbines and clean energy for what's going on.
I didn't I don't know that. But certainly
I've read similar analyzes and it's very
clear that the problem here is not wind turbines.
Yeah, yeah. But anyways, thanks for taking my
call, David. All right. Thanks very much there.
Scipio from California. Great to hear from you.
Let's see, where are we going to go next? There's
a lot of very interesting people wanting to get
on. Let's go to Daryn from the United Kingdom.
Daryn, from the U.K., you're on the air.
David, yes, a great program. Thank you. So I have
a lighthearted question for you. All right, so
when Netflix Mike Insurrection, the TV show, who
would you cast as a Trump, McConnell and Giuliani?
Oh, wow, I have no idea, I would trump
McConnell and Julie, I don't know,
I mean, maybe Trump, it would be Alec
Baldwin. I think the real question is
who will cast who will be cast as me? And I
think I would like it to be Joseph Gordon Levitt,
if I'm totally honest with you.
Like a puppet show. Keep the faith.
OK, thank you very much, a very, very powerful
question. If anybody knows Joseph Gordon Levitt,
let's see if we can make that happen. I would like
it if he portrayed me. That would be really good